and most important I hope that you are
safe because the crypto Market really
shaked yesterday uh there was basically
some news that nobody expected and it
was that the SEC sued the binance CEO
and also declared some altcoins and
security so you can see that the market
reacted quickly and just in a few hours
it dropped a five and a half percent
okay
um that was quite vile I would say again
in yesterday's video in the first four
minutes of the video we were talking
about this range here okay and you can
see in this range again we were saying
that there is always liquidity above the
previous high so that would be in this
Zone that they took already here in this
deviation and also below the previous
lows and you can see that they just took
the liquidity so we're saying that the
most logical move for the market is you
know
to come and take these lows and then
because we have a quick here we could
see some kind of deviation and then
recover this song
now I want to talk about the deviation
possibility because now the market has
moved we can see the price action we can
see the possibilities and we're going to
talk about that in a minute okay but we
were saying that a big move was gonna
happen soon a two thousand dollars move
uh the logic was still lost that was
going to be next week because we have
the International decision with the Dot
Plot CPI data so next week we thought
was going to be the week but this is the
crypto Market guys um in any second you
just see a big move happening okay
that's basically what happened so uh I'm
not claiming victory for this even if we
say that I was likely that they take
this lows uh for me timing is everything
um because you know you can I can give
you now 10 targets but the important
thing in my opinion is that I tell you
when they can get there okay so of
course I didn't expect this move to
happen yesterday now if you go into
Twitter now you're gonna see a lot of
people uh saying that they are buying
the bottom of this drop price is gonna
Bounce from here okay some other people
are saying that now we're gonna go uh
lower okay so uh let's try to make sense
of what is going on in the chart okay
you have this range here okay that's
quite clear I think we all can agree
that this is a range uh pricing doesn't
come to the lows of this range because
you have a quick here so you know if you
first at least 50 of the week then price
can bounce okay that's what I did you
swept the highs for now
it has a broken below the lows all right
and the question is is this a deviation
all right and now we're going to go
higher and game inside this range or
I'm gonna drop lower so the first thing
I want to tell you
is that in my opinion this is not a Zone
to make business and I'm gonna tell you
why first of all anybody that is
claiming the Darby in the bottom of this
drop you guys have no Confluence for it
why because you've just broken below
this range okay if I flip the chart
are you going to short this
okay uh think about that now you can see
here
quite a lot of weeks testing the bottom
of this range as resistance okay it's
telling me that this might not be a
deviation and price might just be
preparing for another leg down okay and
even
if there's a deviation here and it
claims the range there is a level that
it needs to be claimed before going into
Longs in a safe way okay and that would
be the this level over here
yeah I mark it for you
okay so yellow line here you can see
this level here it's very important why
because if now
if we recovers from here okay get inside
the range it can test this level here
and then you can see another self
and that could be
a short entry point even okay so uh what
you want to see before claiming victory
for that you've bought the bottom of
this drop is
don't want to see this becoming into
elevation get back into the range and
then get both this line here test it as
resistance and that's when you can enter
long at twenty six thousand one hundred
twenty at support not a resistance okay
and that's when you can Target this
liquid here this week here
um this week here all right otherwise as
long as this doesn't happen and price
doesn't get back above 26 120 then you
have no Confluence to believe the price
can't go lower okay because again diff
just broken below this range so what
about if price is preparing for another
leg down
all right let's now try to go into
higher time frame think with the
potential lockdown could be
okay uh you have here
this level that we've been talking for
ages and a lot of drivers well most
Traders probably are looking into this
level
to buy and that's uh 25
200 11 okay or 25 250.
all right so what's wrong with this
level the story behind this level is
that you saw two sell-offs happening
from here okay that's your first selloff
then price recovers another sell-off so
that was a very strong resistance that
you want to see price testing at the
support and you can see that it didn't
really do that okay so that's why a lot
of Traders believe that we're gonna go
to 25 250 to this yellow line test the
support and then bounce
but what happens when everybody is
expecting the same thing
that it doesn't play out
that the market meaning it is not gonna
give you that sweet trade okay so then
if you cannot see the deviation and get
above this range on 26 120 and then
bounce okay so if you don't see that
happening then we're gonna favor lower
prices
okay and we are not one of favor I mean
let me get this straight to you I don't
believe
that price can go to 25 250 and then
bounce from there okay because that's
what everybody's expecting so in my
opinion if price continues going lower
from here the most likely thing is the
price zooms a bit lower
okay you're gonna have a lot of three
that's going along here the rest stop
loss and liquidations they're gonna get
hit I'm sorry guys and a lot of people
that are buying in sport they're gonna
see price continue dumping they're gonna
panic and they're gonna sell all right
it's as simple as that the market is
going to trap them because everybody's
looking at the same level to buy
so that's why I think price is not gonna
Bounce from there the most likely thing
in my opinion is that actually goes here
to this Zone over here okay and that
would be
the market for you
this Zone here
let's change the color so you can see
better
maybe in white
all right there you go maybe between 24
670 and 24 200 okay so that zone is in
my opinion the zone to make business
right because then what you could see is
price dumping here then here if you can
hold okay then you are looking here to
see some kind of reversal pattern maybe
a double baby bottom here or mainly
links to the downside the price now
breaking below this Zone that's when you
can consider to go long okay or maybe
you can recover this this level again
all right again maybe here you come here
and then you see another sell-off but
for at least you can take advantage of
this uh at least one thousand dollar
move all right so that's what I think at
the moment uh if you are considering to
half long order so by orders are 25 200
Zone
please be careful
please be careful because I can't
imagine uh that everybody wins here okay
uh usually
people lose
And when everybody is thinking about the
same trade
it usually doesn't play a while okay
um that's what I think guys so a quick
recap of what we've said is you are
getting into the folder time frame
you have this range here the blue lines
here okay that's your range we've been
here for quite some time we've been here
for one month okay now price has broken
below this could be a deviation but for
that you need to see price
recovering
this one over here okay so first you
need to see price getting inside this
range and then very important gap of
this level 26 120 that's when you come
along okay so this is your Zone to make
a business if you see a recovery okay
that's your song where you can go long
yes you want to lose my Precision in
price okay you want to lose a two
percent move but what's the problem are
you gonna risk to catch a knife here
it doesn't make more sense
honestly it doesn't really make much
sense also when you have this week see a
testing it as resistance okay and that
is telling you that it's likely that
price continues going lower
uh again if it goes lower
I know everybody's looking at 25 200. I
don't believe that this song can hold so
sorry I'm gonna remove it from my
Charter straight away price would go
lower and between 24
224 700 that's the sun where you could
see price holding hopefully and going
higher okay that's basically what I
think of course you know you can start
to mark this new imbalances that you
have in the chart I'm not gonna lie to
you that is of course a lot of liquidity
upside you have this liquidity pool you
have also uh actually another liquid
here
okay you have this week here that's the
50 of the week that's 150 of the week so
there is a lot of liquidity to the
upside the pool
before price comes again towards this
liquidity it can still go lower okay
that's the thing that you have to
consider that because there is equated
upside doesn't mean
the price
is gonna go there immediately so let's
see how price action develops uh again
26 120 that's your level
to go long and if you start to lose
these levels over here that's when
you're gonna see the next drop towards
this one here so that's what I want to
say guys uh please don't try to catch
this knife okay because you know you are
right now below resistant you are
testing the resistance and in order for
you to go along and try to fill these
imbalances here this liquidity pool this
week and this week you need to get above
this level here that we set dice 26 120.
if you recover this level that's when
you can long right otherwise they're
gonna go lower 25 200 I don't think it's
going to hold guys and uh there are
easier trades that you can take today
all right so for example if you go into
Dot
okay
you don't want to see well if you're
going to somal Queens you're going to be
able to sit here some weeks okay look at
this week here for polkadot
so do you have here some targets that
you can short until okay so you can
short and take profits at 497 and 490
okay trust me these levels will probably
get filled again it's not Financial
advice but that's what the experience
tells me okay that if we see a long week
like this then price will eventually
fill the week
more altcoins maybe chain link let's
check uh chain link has already filled
the week if you noticed
it does the 50 of the week here
okay so they feel they're weak so try to
find those altcoins that haven't filled
the week yet okay
for example a cytophan either
not weak in either uh more the
checkmatic
Matic wow Matic is really dropping no no
rest formatic uh more maybe Gala
um
it hasn't recovered the 50 yet okay
because those levels would be this
and also
2594 okay but still the one of polka
that looks the most interesting at the
moment
I'm trying to find
trying to think of a more more altcoins
Solana there it is recover in the week
you can see
okay he already has recovered the 50 of
the week there
1946 okay it can still go to 1903 that's
the 100 of the weakable try to find
those altcoins that haven't failed the
week check this okay something similar
happened here you have this week here
okay the red candle and then
pretty soon after that week gets filled
by another week okay I'm not saying that
it's gonna feel a week and continue
going higher it can feel the weak and
continue to go lower ball you can at
least for example in the case of
polkadot
try to find a place to go into a short
and take profits at those levels okay
those are the trades that you need to
try to find today
don't go into Bitcoin and try too long
here because it doesn't make any sense
all right don't try to be a hero that's
pretty much everything guys uh
so anyway I hope that you are safe from
yesterday on and you didn't lose money
and if you did uh keep grinding because
you can always recover it okay it might
take some time but you know
trading in the right direction and
making the right efficient you can make
the money back so it's not the end a lot
of Traders have lost a lot of money in
the past and then they've made it uh
after uh now they're thriving okay so a
bit of inspiration if you are struggling
today from yesterday and that's what I
want to say guys
also before I finish the video I'll see
it again you can treat immediate Link in
the description it's a an exchange that
doesn't require kyc all right now if you
are from the US or Canada or Singapore
you wanna need VPN to trade there we're
also gonna do more giveaways for
retrieving course there
um there are some rewards for deposits
okay that could be for example a good
way to recover some money so let's say
that for example if you deposit a
thousand dollars into bit yet in the
link in the description and you're gonna
get 10 payback so you would get a
hundred dollars okay uh there are ways
to try to balance a bit if you lost
money yesterday I hope it's not the case
again
um thank you so much for watching guys
have a good day
and I'll see you soon